une fusillade s'est produite au centre
culturel islamique de québec
on a parlé à des gens qui ont vu des
civières des ambulances quitter le
centre culturel islamique et le secteur
autour de la mosquée et complètement
bouclé son événement de chez l'humain
rajic les oncles montréal qui ont dû
intervenir sur l'autoroute à la demande
de la sûreté du québec une situation
exceptionnelle nous continuons à suivre
une évolution des feux de forêt en
colombie britannique
les gens ici s'inquiète se demande
qu'est ce qui se passe avec leur maison
à peu près de 14000 personnes qui sont
évacués dix mille personnes sont sur le
pied d'alliances dès l'alerté amber ça a
été vraiment la consternation la famille
d'yves on l'a cassée et les policiers de
la sûreté du québec
leurs recherches hugo freud est est
évidemment toujours incarcéré le drame
lui a eu des répercussions dans tout le
pays depuis deux jours l'ouragan maria a
semé la dévastation dans les caraïbes
la tempête a frappé durement porto rico
aujourd'hui c'est la plus violente que
l'ailé connu en près de 90 ans
quel est le choix des français c'est
emmanuel macron avec 65,1 % c'est le
parti qui va le propulser au pouvoir il
y a plus d' abstention que de vote pour
madame le pen
[Applaudissements]
le bilan qui s'est alourdi on parle
maintenant de plus de 50 morts et de
plus de 200 blessés lors de cette
fusillade à las vegas la chute d'un des
plus puissants producteurs d'hollywood
se poursuit un v-twin steen a été
congédié ce soir de sa société de
production pour avoir harcelé de
nombreuses femmes de l'industrie du
cinéma américain pendant des décennies
célébration ici risque fort d'être de
courte durée car au même moment les
députés catalans vont être en faveur de
l'indépendance madrid préparait sa
riposte
une riposte légal et drastiques
allez les plantes à déloger denis
coderre de la mairie de montréal
véritable tour de force elle rayonnait
de bonheur
[Musique]
on a vu ce pont c'est finalement toutes
les couleurs que le fonds aura au cours
des prochaines semaines